[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
george floyd's girlfriend takes the
stand in the derek chauvin trial
her testimony about their opioid edition
and
their nearly three year long
relationship what were you saved in his
phone ass
mama we investigate who's the man seen
in the car with george floyd
on the day of his death and why is he
refusing to testify at trial
our reporters dig into the long criminal
history of morris hall
and the never before seen body cam
footage from derek shauvin
the moment his camera falls to the
ground during the struggle
plus what derek shoven told one
eyewitness moments after
george floyd was taken away in an
ambulance he's going to control this guy
because he's a sizable guy
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm brian ross in our studios in new
york
with brian buckmeyer on assignment in
minneapolis for the trial of derek
shoved
and with us as always of course is terry
austin big day of testimony in the
derrick chauvin trial
as the girlfriend of george floyd talks
about their drug use
and the man they bought their drugs from
that man was in the carbon floyd
on the day he died but before we get to
that brian buckmeyer here to explain
what's called
the spark of life testimony from floyd's
girlfriend
brian yeah brian the spark of life
testimony interestingly enough comes
from a 1985
minnesota supreme court case where an
officer
was killed and the prosecutor was
allowed to bring in information
of his past the court said that a
prosecutor is allowed to show that a
person who's deceased is more than just
skin tendons and bones
that they actually had a spark of life
before their death however
they cannot use that testimony to
inflame the passions
of the jury now ross no relation to
brian ross
the witness says she met floyd in august
of 2017.
she says her his pet name for her was
mama
she says floyd struggled with drug
addiction especially after his mother's
death
in 2018 but they both tried to get clean
in march 2020
while the country went into lockdown for
the beginning of the coven 19 pandemic
it's a classic story of
uh how many people get addicted to
opioids
we both suffered from chronic pain
mine was in my neck and his was in his
back
was there a period then after march
where you thought the two of you had
both been able to quit for a while yes a
long period
kind of going forward to may of 2020 was
there a time when
you thought he might be using again
yes it was the same type of thing
just behavior changes influence
and did you also kind of fall back to
using
opioids in may of 2020. one time yes
and he was aware of that yes
on cross-examination of courtney ross
the defense questioned her about an
overdose that nearly killed floyd
two months before he died
he wasn't feeling good his stomach
really hurt he was doubled over in pain
just wasn't feeling well and he said he
had to go to the hospital so
i took him straight to the hospital did
you notice foam coming from his mouth
um i i noticed like some kind of
like you know foam building in the
corners of his mouth kind of
dry a dry white substance
[Music]
and did you learn what that what caused
that overdose
no at that time frame did you learn that
mr floyd was taking anything other than
opioids
no
you did not know that he had taken
heroin at that time
no the defense then moved on to ask her
about her statements to the fbi which is
also investigating the case
fbi agents asked her about buying drugs
just a week
before floyd's death we
got pills and made that remind me of the
same
feeling i don't know if they were the
same pills i don't know
where they came from okay so you had a
second experience
with those pills right or a similar
feeling to those pills
i had a similar experience yes right
and that was approximately a week before
mr floyd's passing
yes and by similar experience
um you
[Music]
uh you recall telling the fbi that when
you had
that you felt like you were going to die
i don't remember saying that but i i did
see it in the transcript
and is that how you felt like you were
going to die i don't remember feeling
that way no
i that i didn't recall even saying that
on redirect prosecutors tried to show
that ross and floyd took similar drugs
in the past
and did not die from them
so the pills that we were talking about
you obtained in march yes
that caused you to feel jittery and were
different
did you also see mr floyd taking that
kind of pill
we did not take them together that time
um
did you think that he had some of them
for himself yes
um obviously he did not die in march no
and the pill that gave you a similar
experience in may
yes yes did he have some of those pills
as well
yes did he take some of those pills in
may
yes he did not die before
may 25th of 2020 correct yes
so let's talk about courtney ross brian
her testimony began with an emotional
description of the relationship
painting george floyd really is a very
decent man didn't she
yeah she did i think the testimony can
actually be probably used by both sides
i would expect eric nelson to highlight
the drug use
and how often he had used it but of
course the prosecution's going to use
the fact that
he used the drugs in the past i think
the redirect was very powerful
you're definitely going to hear that on
summation and that he didn't die in
march or earlier times
also bringing up the use of opioids i
think in the cleanest of ways
trying to pull the sting away from the
defense everyone in the country knows we
have an opioid crisis going on
many people abusing those drugs after
using them for prescription pain
right and terry has the prosecutor
raised george floyd's opiate addiction
and the defense hammered on it
what role do you think it will play in
the minds of the jurors
you know i think it will raise some
reasonable doubt the prosecution
had to raise the issue because it's
going to come out in the medical
information when that comes out a little
bit later on in the trial
there's really no way to get around that
issue eric nelson
actually started out by saying i'm
really sorry to courtney
about her opioid addiction but then he
hammered it just like you said
he started talking about did you know
there was heroin use as far as george
floyd was concerned did you know he used
it right before he passed away
so he hammered it in and i think it was
just enough for the jury to wonder
whether or not that contributed to his
death all right thanks terry
still ahead on law and crime daily did
police follow procedure
while restraining george floyd but first
more on who morris hall is and why he's
refusing to testify
we investigate the man of the car with
floyd on the day he died
next
[Music]
the man who was in the suv with george
floyd when police approached
is now refusing to testify law and
crime's antoinette levy has been digging
into the background of a man by the name
of maurice hall
and jeanette brian maurice hall's
attorney filed a document with the court
saying that he would invoke his fifth
amendment rights against
self-incrimination
hall was actually wanted on drug charges
out of minnesota
the night that floyd died
sir i just came about traveling and when
i bought a tablet
[Music]
the man in the red hat is maurice hall
he was in george floyd's suv
when police approached floyd on may 25
2020.
the woman next to him is shawanda hill
hall came up in testimony from floyd's
girlfriend
courtney ross are you familiar with
maurice hall
yes and was maurice hall the person that
you and mr floyd
bought controlled substances from we had
court documents show hall was wanted in
hennepin county minnesota
on charges of being a felon in
possession of a firearm
third degree drug possession and
domestic assault judge cahill signed one
of those warrants in february 2020
three months before floyd died hall went
to texas
after floyd's death authorities in
minnesota considered him a fugitive
and asked police in texas to arrest him
hall was taken into custody
a week after floyd died he gets extra
attention
good or bad hall has granted a number of
interviews to media outlets
including cnn but now he says he won't
say anything
if called to testify at derrick
chauvin's trial
his attorney has asked the court to
quash the subpoena
since anything hall testifies to could
be used against him in court
i didn't like maurice very much no
floyd's girlfriend testified pills she
and floyd had taken together were
different
from pills they had taken in the past
usually
opioid to me is like it's a pain
reliever
it's something that is
you know kind of relaxing takes your
pain away
the pill that time it
seemed like it was a really strong
stimulant i couldn't sleep all night
i felt very jittery
maurice hall actually has a lengthy
criminal record out of
texas a lot of drug cases there for him
he's actually currently in jail in
minneapolis and
in hennepin county he's accused of
violating a protection order for a woman
he pleaded guilty to
strangling his present prison sentence
in that case was actually stayed so now
he's back in jail for violating that
order and he's also accused
of assaulting that person yet again his
public defender declined
comment when i reached her brian thanks
angenet fascinating report brian
buckmeyer
how important might his testimony be and
can the prosecution
force him somehow to testify
not really uh his testimony would have
been important i think what would have
been smart is the prosecution
gives him immunity for any testimony he
would have had
if he was going to testify about selling
drugs to george floyd
you got to go for the big fish here let
him go on any kind of low level
two or three pill sales because you're
going after a conviction
for a murder in the second degree i
think that would have been the smart
move it's a miscalculation in my mind by
the prosecution
and terry he's now the mystery man in
this case who wants him more to testify
the prosecution or the defense
there's no question brian that the
defense wants him to
testify because you know chauvin wants
to show that floyd was a quote unquote
drug addict
and that he may have had bad drugs or
lace drugs in his system
prior to may 25th and that that
contributed to his
death it also shows that floyd was
fraternizing with an alleged drug dealer
so
all of these things are painting floyd
as a bad person
this is what the defense would want to
do
there's a possibility of course that the
prosecution can rehabilitate all that
but this is definitely a witness the
defense wants on that stand
and anjanet is there any word on whether
shawanda hill the woman who was in the
car with george floyd that night will
she testify
she's expected to testify in opening
statements eric nelson said that we
would hear both from shawanda hill
and maurice hall uh obviously we don't
know what's going to happen now that
this
has come up who knows what shawanda hill
will do after maurice hall has
uh made this move but it's all very
interesting
and it is interesting that he was
actually eric nelson was able to get
some of that information about maurice
hall
in through courtney ross since he
probably knows now that he won't be
testifying
all right well coming up on law and
crime daily we'll hear from derek chovin
himself
on the day of george floyd's death plus
the dramatic moment paramedics finally
arrived on the scene
could george floyd been saved if they
came sooner
as we've seen a major point in the
derrick chopin trial is why the officer
did not put floyd on his side while
restraining him known as
the recovery position one of the
paramedics responding to the scene
testified what he saw when he arrived
i can't remember exact details i
remember he was on the ground and he had
handcuffs in place
do you remember calling saying that he
was primarily on his left
side
i think i did say that yes okay and is
that what you recall
today uh he wasn't i i yeah i don't i
don't remember if i clarified that at
all like
um to me it seemed like he was leaned to
his left is kind of i think what i tried
to say
so he was kind of lean to his left and i
think he said and he was sort of rolled
forward
onto his stomach a little bit yes would
it i mean would you dispute me if i say
that's what the transcript
refers to no okay
let's talk about this brian buckmart
it's well known there's a training video
shown to minneapolis police officers
how important it is to put a suspect on
their side
does this suggest chauvin was ignoring
what he had been trained to or just
never was trained that's what the
prosecution is definitely going to argue
brian that there's a specific
mode of transportation or how you move a
body after it's been put in that
position
this witness also talks about just
having someone face first with their
physical body putting pressure
on their lungs on top of the ground and
how a person is supposed to be put into
a recovered position when the emt is on
their way
that's part of showman's training if you
didn't do that as the video
is outlining to us that's going to take
away from eric nelson's
main point and main argument here right
and terry austin for the defense for
eric nelson
how does he deal with the testimony
about this and what is really a bad
fact for the defense it's a terrible
fact not only did chovin not do what he
should have done
based on his training but you know he
did nothing
and i think the fact that the other two
officers
were telling him take the pulse or maybe
we should turn him over
will hurt him the only thing he can do
is basically say and he did ask
both of the paramedics who or the emt
who came to the scene
whether or not the police were as well
trained as
they were when they came to the scene
and so the point was you know that they
did chest compressions they did
you know they tried to stop uh his
fluids and all of the other things that
were happening get an iv inside of him
and i think that's all he can do is to
show that the police were not as well
trained as the emt or the paramedics
all right well when we come back we're
now seeing what was on
derrick shovin's body camera what it was
like as the former minneapolis police
officer arrived
as george floyd was being taken into
custody next
as we've seen the newly released police
body cam videos show a number of
different perspectives
of what was actually happening that day
we're now learning that derek shovin's
body cam
was knocked off of him and fell under a
car during the struggle with george
floyd
[Music]
please
oh
and the camera fell to the ground we've
told you about some of the most powerful
testimony when eyewitness
charles mcmillian broke down in tears on
the stand
but his conversation with the former
minneapolis police officer
inside a patrol car is giving us new
insight
into derrick shelvin's mindset
you advise the fire department if
they're
[Music]
to your family and what were you trying
to do
um at that point in time when you were
talking to mr shopping why did you feel
the need to talk to mr chavin
because what i watched was wrong and did
you feel
it was important to tell him that yes
ma'am
so we heard sheldon say it's one
person's opinion brian bucknighter does
it raise the question of whether
derek shoving should testify in his own
behalf in this trial
brian i'm as a defense attorney just
generally risk averse to having
a client testify because it can open up
a pandora's box for
derek chovin in that any bad act that he
maybe had in the past
could be on display for the jury that
they may not have heard if he didn't
testify
but on the other hand he's got to
explain some of this we're hearing a bit
of his explanation there
where he's saying he's a big guy he's
probably on something that may be enough
for the defense but he may be a fact
that he has to explain that a little bit
more we've got to wait to see
terry as brian was saying most lawyers
don't want to put their clients on the
stand but police officers are trained to
testify
so does that change the equation here
well you know it does help the fact that
he's trained to testify
but i think it would really hurt i agree
with brian buckmeyer here i think it
would really hurt to put derek chovin on
the stand
first of all his personality is cold and
calculated and i don't think the jury is
going to receive that well
and second of all how can you really
explain the fact that you kept your knee
on his neck even when there was no pulse
even when there was no breathing and
even when there was no moving i think
there's just no way to explain that
and i think if eric nelson puts derek
tobin
on that stand you're going to have the
prosecution
cut into him and try to ask those
questions and there will be no
answer to those questions because there
is no excuse for not moving at least
at that point all right and brian does
the case now
with the first week almost at the end
seem to be on schedule what's left for
the prosecution now
yeah it appears that the prosecution
will probably put on some more witnesses
uh later today we saw that there was a
shift sergeant who was testifying
he brought in some information about
some of the policies i think we're going
to start to see a turn
for the prosecution talking about those
policies and seeing whether or not what
derek shoving did on that day
was proper and sound it's a strong
argument by the defense so far
i think the prosecution's got to try to
figure out how to head that off
at the path and we're going to see that
in the coming days and also terry will
expect to hear a lot about the actual
cause of death
absolutely all the medical evidence is
going to come in soon
all right well thank you so much for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in
america
[Music]
you